Good morning, #Believenation!
Today's message is "be patient."
Over to you, L.L.Cool J.
(intro music)
Where I come from, people are very passionate.
Hot-blooded.
They want it- they want it, now!
I need it right away. Everyone's lookin' for a shortcut but sometimes
-its-
-sometimes-
an indirect route
is the quickest way to get there.
Sometimes you gotta take a little longer
to achieve the things you wanna achieve in life.
So don't be in a hurry
Be patient.
Everybody wants everything now. (snaps)
We live in a society where it's "instant-gratification."
Instagram, insta-this
Be patient.
I think it's important to remember that you need to be patient
but not lazy.
I think a lot of people
make the connection between the two, where
you're waiting for something to happen, and until it happens, you just don't do anything else.
The key is that you hustle
while you wait.
Waiting is a part of the game
but it doesn't mean you're not doing anything while you wait,
and you're developing other opportunities,
while you wait.
You hustle, while you wait.
So as an example, if i wanted to grow this Salsa Dance business, right?
I want to grow the studio
I want to get lots more students coming in,
I wanna grow a customer base
I want us to be well-known...
One of the things I might to do
is take out a direct-mail campaign.
Ok? I'm going to do a direct mail campaign
and I'm going to blast
cards to everyone who's in
a 10-mile radius
of this studio.
That's gonna take some time, right?
It's gonna take some time to develop the artwork
to then
figure out how we're going to distribute them.
get them into the hands of the people living in the neighborhoods.
to then
wait for the next schedule to open up for people to sign up
wait for them to actually come and buy a class
to then
wait for them to actually come and
put their money down
and show up for the class, right?
That's a process
it takes time.
I need to wait for that to happen
but while I'm waiting for that to happen
I'm not just sitting on my hands.
I'm doing other things because
my goal is to grow this business.
So I'm going to be making youtube videos
I'm going to be
improving the customer experience.
improving the location and the environment.
I'm going to be looking at: what's the signage
that we have coming out here?
I'm going to be looking at
what else can I do with social media?
What else can I do to get into mainstream media?
I'm going to be HUSTLING...
...while I'm waiting.
So waiting is part of the game, but don't be lazy
don't just wait on one thing to happen
start other projects!
While you're waiting for the first thing to happen.
don't be lazy.
#believe.
So the question of the day, today, for you guys is:
Two parts-
One, are you patient?
And two,
what do you do
when you're being impatient and waiting for something to happen?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching,
have an amazing day,
continue to #believe,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning for another shot
of #Entspresso !
(outro music)